In this segment, we
point out and discuss
some important but also
intuitive properties
of conditional expectations.
The first property is the
one that is written up here.
What is the intuitive meaning?
If you condition on Y, then
the value of Y is known,
and so g of Y is also known.
There's no randomness in it.
It can be treated as a
constant, and therefore it
can be pulled outside
the expectation.
So that's the intuition.
How does one establish
such a result formally?
Let us take the discrete case.
So let us assume that X
and Y are both discrete.
What does it take to
establish a fact of this kind?
We want to show that two
random variables are equal,
and that amounts
to the following.
We consider an outcome
of the experiment,
and we want to
show that whatever
the outcome of
the experiment is,
these two random variables
will be the same.
So let us consider an outcome
for which the random variable,
Y, takes a specific
value, little y.
And of course, this has to
be a specific little y that
is possible.
Otherwise, conditioning on that
event would not be meaningful.
So if an outcome has this
value for the random variable,
Y, then what does the
random variable do?
This is, by definition,
the random variable
that takes the
value-- expected value
of g Y X, conditional
expectation,
given that capital Y
took on this value.
This was our definition
of the concept
of the abstract
conditional expectation
as a random variable.
This is the random
variable that takes
this specific numerical
value whenever
the random variable, capital
Y, takes the value, little y.
And similarly, if the
random variable, capital Y,
takes the value, little y,
this random variable here
is the expected value of X,
given that Y is little y.
And when capital
Y takes the value,
little y, this
function, g of Y, takes
on this particular
numerical value.
So we want to show that
these two expressions
we will be equal no
matter what capital Y is.
Now, when we place ourselves in
a conditional universe, where
capital Y takes a
value, little y,
then the joint PMF
of X and Y gets
concentrated on those
values of capital Y
that obey this relation.
So conditioned on
this event, capital Y
is, with certainty,
equal to little y.
Therefore, this
random variable here,
in the conditional universe,
is the same as this number.
But now, since this
is a number, it
can be pulled outside
the expectation.
So we have concluded that
for any outcome for which
the random variable, capital
Y, takes this specific value,
little y, this random
variable takes this value.
This random variable
takes this value.
They are the same.
So no matter what
the outcome is,
these two random variables
take the same value,
and therefore they are
the same random variables.
Now, this is a correct proof
if the random variables
are discrete.
If the random variables
are continuous or general,
then carrying out a rigorous
proof is actually quite subtle,
and it is beyond our scope.
However, the intuition
is still correct,
and the result is correct.
And we will be using it
freely whenever we need to.
Let us now move to a
second observation.
Suppose that h is an
invertible function.
What does that mean?
That if I give you
the value of h,
you can tell me the
value of the argument.
So in some sense,
Y and h of Y can
be recovered from each other.
If I give you Y, you
can calculate h of Y.
But also, if I give you h of Y,
you can figure out what Y was.
An example could be
the function, h of Y,
equals Y to the third power.
If I tell you the value
of Y, you know Y cubed.
But if I tell you Y cubed,
you can also figure out Y.
So Y and Y cubed carry
exactly the same information.
In that case, the
conditional expectation--
what you expect, on the
average, X to be-- if I tell you
the value of Y, should be the
same as what you would expect
X to be if I give you the
value of, let's say, Y cubed.
In both cases, I'm giving you
the same amount of information,
so the conditional distribution
of X should be the same.
And the conditional expectations
should also be the same.
So this is, again, a
very intuitive fact.
How do we verify that
this fact is true?
Using the same method as before.
So fix some particular
outcome for which
the random variable, capital Y,
takes a specific value, little
y.
When that happens,
this random variable
will take this value here.
That's just by the definition
of conditional expectation.
This is the random variable
that takes this value whenever
capital Y happens to
be equal to little y.
In that case, we also
have that h of capital
Y takes on a specific
value, h of little y.
When this random variable
takes this specific value,
this random variable here will
take a value of this kind.
So this is the
random variable that
takes this value
whenever h of capital Y
happens to be this
specific number.
But now, the event that h of
Y takes this specific value,
because the function,
h, is invertible,
is identical to the event that
Y takes that particular value.
And so, since this event
is identical to that event,
the conditional probabilities,
given this event,
would be the same as the
conditional probabilities given
that the event.
And therefore, the
conditional expectations
would also be the same.
Once more, this
is a proof that's
entirely rigorous
if we are dealing
with discrete random
variables, although
in the continuous
case, there could
be some subtleties involved.
However, the result
is true in general.
The technical details
are beyond our scope.